today governor steve sissellach
acknowledged nevada's vulnerable and
minority communities are not getting the
coronavirus vaccines they need
he released a video this morning
promising the state will do better
the zip codes that continue to
experience the highest number
of covid19 cases are the same zip codes
with the lowest frequency of
vaccinations that makes no sense
these zip codes represent southern
nevada's working class families
lower income households in communities
of color
governor sysolak added nevada's
vaccination playbook isn't being
followed
and he says that's leading to an unfair
allocation of vaccines
a report from the southern nevada health
district shows vaccine distribution
doesn't reflect the demographics of our
valley essentially
minority communities are not getting
enough vaccines
in an effort to help inform the
community the organization reach is
reaching is hosting rather a forum
tonight to inform our spanish speaking
community about the vaccine
we have more information about this at
8newsnow.com we'll have more on the
governor's
discussion later on other newscasts